Simplifica -1 por esta expresión que está entre
corchetes: [(-7) + 2 (3 + 2)] - (5)². Este es
un problema de orden de operaciones y recuerda
el orden de las operaciones, siempre resolvemos
primero lo que está entre paréntesis: primero
los paréntesis, luego hacemos los exponentes
-hay un exponente en este problema justo aquí-,
luego hacemos la multiplicación -multiplicación
y división- y por último sumas y restas. Así que
intentemos abordar esto lo mejor que podamos.
Primero resolvamos lo que está entre paréntesis.
Aquí tenemos (3 + 2) que es igual a 5; y veamos,
podríamos hacer otras cosas en otras partes de
esta expresión que no afecten lo que tenemos aquí
entre paréntesis. Tenemos - (5)², estamos restando
un (5)²; queremos resolver el exponente antes de
hacer la resta, así que este (5)² lo podemos
reescribir como 25. No hagamos demasiados pasos
a la vez. Así que todo esto se simplifica como
-1. Y luego entre corchetes tenemos (-7) + 2 •
5 y cerramos los corchetes, - 25. Ahora queremos
hacer una multiplicación. Podrían decir "Espera,
todavía tenemos un paréntesis aquí, ¿por qué no
resolvemos eso primero?" Pero cuando evaluamos lo
que hay dentro de este paréntesis sólo obtenemos
un -7, realmente no cambia nada, así que podemos
dejarlo como -7. Queremos evaluar toda esta
expresión antes de hacer cualquier otra cosa,
es decir, podríamos distribuir este -1 y todo
esto, pero sigamos el orden de las operaciones.
Así que evaluemos esta expresión, queremos hacer
la multiplicación antes de sumar cualquier cosa;
entonces aquí tenemos 2 • 5, 2 • 5 = 10, esto
es igual a 10. No tendríamos que reescribir
la expresión muchas veces, pero lo haremos en esta
ocasión para asegurarnos de que nadie se confunda.
Así que esto es igual a -1 (-7) + 10 y cerramos
los corchetes, - 25. Ahora podemos calcular esto
con bastante facilidad: -7 + 10, comenzamos
en -7. Vamos a dibujar una recta numérica,
comenzamos en -7, la longitud de esta
línea es -7 y luego le vamos a sumar 10,
así que nos vamos a mover 10 a la derecha; si nos
movemos 7 hacia la derecha volvemos a 0, y luego
vamos a avanzar 3 más, así que vamos a ir al 7,
8, 9, 10, de modo que esto nos lleva a 3 positivo.
Otra forma de pensar en ello es que estamos
sumando números enteros de diferentes signos,
podemos ver la suma como si fuera la diferencia
de los enteros, y como el entero mayor es positivo
nuestra respuesta será positiva. Entonces,
literalmente, podríamos ver esto como 10 - 7,
10 - 7 = 3 así que el resultado de esto es 3,
y entonces toda nuestra expresión se vuelve -1
(3). Y para que quede claro, los corchetes y
paréntesis en realidad son lo mismo; a veces
la gente escribe los corchetes alrededor de muchos
paréntesis para que sea un poco más fácil de leer,
pero en realidad son lo mismo que los paréntesis.
Así que los corchetes que tenemos aquí los
podríamos escribir así y luego tenemos -25 por
aquí. Ahora, una vez más, queremos resolver la
multiplicación o división antes que las sumas
y restas, entonces multipliquemos -1 (3) = - 3,
y ahora tenemos que restar 25, de modo que -3
- 25 -estamos sumando dos números enteros del
mismo signo-, ya estamos en -3 y tenemos que ir
25 hacia la dirección negativa, nos movemos 25
hacia la izquierda o podemos verlo como 3 + 25
= 28, pero como lo estamos haciendo en dirección
de los negativos, entonces el resultado es -28.
Entonces esto es igual a -28, y hemos terminado.